at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can I also do personal question
now it is seen
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton books I've loved
on the Tim Ferriss show is exclusively
brought to you by audible there couldn't
be a better sponsor for this series my
dear listeners and readers I have used
audible for so many years as long as I
can remember I love it
audible has the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet I listen when
I'm taking walks I listen while I'm
cooking I listen whenever I can and if
you're looking for a place to start
I can recommend three of my favorites
the first is the Tao of Seneca by Seneca
if you want to hear my favorite letters
of all time touches on stoic philosophy
calmness under duress etc the next is
the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman GA IMA
n one of my favorites even if you're a
nonfiction purist this is the fiction
book that you need to listen to neo also
has perhaps the most calming voice of
all time in 3rd Gregg McEwan's
essentialism subtitle the disciplined
pursuit of less this is one of my
favourite books of the past few years
combines very well with the 80/20
principle but more inaudible every month
audible members get one credit for any
audiobook on the site plus a choice of
multiple audible originals from a
rotating selection they also get access
to daily news digests from the likes of
the New York Times Wall Street Journal
and The Washington Post as well as
guided meditation programs and here are
some other amazing audible features and
I use a bunch of these you can download
titles and listen offline anytime
anywhere I use this feature even when I
could get access I'll put my phone on
say airplane mode because I want to get
bothered with notifications and I'm
taking a walk to clear my head and you
can listen to you titles offline in a
case like that or on a plane or whatever
obviously I'm not flying much these days
the app is free and can be installed on
all smartphones and tablets you can
listen across devices without losing
your spot and whisper sync is another
feature I use quite a lot I love reading
my Kindle in bed for instance then
picking up at the same
act spot where I left off when I go
walking and listening the next day
Kindle and audio versions can be synched
up automatically it's just amazing and
if you can't decide what to listen to
don't sweat it you don't have to rush
you can keep your credits for up to a
year and use them for instance to binge
on a whole series if you like audible
offers just about everything podcasts
guided wellness programs theatrical
performances a list comedy and audible
originals you won't find anywhere else
and right now audible is offering you
guys that's Tim Ferriss show listeners a
free audiobook with a 30-day trial
membership and again my list if you want
to check them out the Tao of Seneca the
graveyard book essentialism those are
just three there's so many good ones out
there just go to audible.com slash Tim
and browse the unmatched selection of
audio programs then download your free
title and start listening it's that easy
let's check it out go to audible.com
slash tim or text tim t IM - 500 500 to
get started today check it out
audible.com slash tim hello boys and
girls ladies and germs this is tim
ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show where it is usually
my job to sit down with world-class
performers of all different types
startup founders investors chess
champions Olympic athletes you name it
to tease out the habits that you can
apply in your own lives this episode
however is an experiment and part of a
short-form series that I'm doing simply
called books I've loved I've invited
some amazing past guests close friends
and new faces to share their favorite
books describe their favorite books the
books that have influenced them changed
them transform them for the better and I
hope you pick up one or two new mentors
in the form of books from this new
series and apply the lessons in your own
life I had a lot of fun putting this
together inviting these people to
participate and have learned so so much
myself I hope that is also the case for
you please enjoy
hi my name is Anne Meara Co I'm a
co-founding partner at floodgate which
is a seed stage venture capital firm in
Palo Alto California our firm is known
really well for investing early or way
too early into the world's craziest
startups and as a result of my investing
experience I was named to the New York
Times top twenty venture capitalist
worldwide in 2019 and that is because I
have backed companies like lyft in
refinery29
before they were even known I'm also a
lecturer in entrepreneurship at Stanford
where I'm a co-director of the Mayfield
Fellows Program I also got my PhD in
math modeling of cybersecurity at
Stanford back in the day and I am also a
co-founding member of all rays which is
a non-profit committed to improving
diversity and funders and founders I am
so excited to talk to you today about
some of the books that I have found to
be really important in my life and to
tell you a little bit about why it's
been life-changing for me so to start
off I thought I would talk about this
book called how will you measure your
life and it's written by a Harvard
Business School professor Clayton
Christensen I love Clayton Christensen's
story because he wrote this book after
he suffered some very significant health
issues and in overcoming the same type
of cancer that had taken his father's
life he started to think about not just
business questions where he had excelled
but really how do you measure your life
and as he thought about this he wrote
this book this very groundbreaking book
about how do you balance your career in
your personal life and what is the
source of happiness even within your
personal life and there's a few lessons
that I thought I would share with you
today about why it made a difference
from
and some of this is actually backwards
looking and some of this is forward
looking so in backwards looking he has
actually even in business a framework
that he talks about around emergent
versus deliberate strategies and he
applies this actually in life and an
emergence strategy is something that
sort of comes up and it's not planned
and that obviously the deliberate is
actually something that is very planned
and he talks about how you balance these
emergent and deliberate occurrences in
your life and I think that in my life
when I look back I was fortunate enough
to have incredible balance between what
emerged and some crazy luck that came
into my life and then also planning for
how I made myself lucky and to give you
an example of what that was like I took
a job I took almost all of my jobs
actually not because of some predestined
plan but because I really thought that
the person I was gonna work with was
incredible and sometimes it fit into
some plan that I had for my life and
sometimes it didn't fit in at all but
every time I took those steps and even
when I couldn't explain it from a
logical standpoint to anyone else if I
knew that the person that I was working
for was going to be a huge source of
inspiration someone I could learn from
it was always the right decision as an
example in 2003 I decided to go back to
my PhD at Stanford and I knew that was
going to be a five to maybe eight year
commitment and a lot of people actually
questioned why I would do that I was
five years into my career most people
went straight into a PhD and yet I felt
this urged this calling to actually go
back and study and this was in 2003 and
in 2003 Google had yet to go public and
there were a lot of people with my work
background who are starting to work
there and for a moment I considered
working in a place like Google and I
remember talking to my husband about
this and saying I just don't know it's
hard to explain but I have to scratch
this itch to get my PhD and ultimately I
remember when Google IPO tie felt like
maybe I had made the wrong call I was
making I think 26 thousand dollars a
year the graduate student stipend but
even that didn't feel bad at the time
and when I knew that I didn't feel badly
about it that's when I knew I made the
right decision and so you know sometimes
there are things that you can plan out
and there are other things that you also
realize in retrospect was a right
decision and it doesn't look like it
makes sense in the moment but your gut
tells you it's the right decision and
sometimes I've learned it's really
important to follow your gut and Clayton
Christensen talks about that the second
thing that I really learned was he talks
about the difficulty of figuring out
what your job is in human relationships
and this comes from a business framework
that clean Christians and talks about
which is what's the job to be done and
when he originally talked about it it
came from a study he'd done at
McDonald's where they studied how people
bought breakfast items and it turned out
that a bunch of people were buying
milkshakes for breakfast
and so McDonald's was trying to figure
out what is this all about should they
sell more milkshakes more flavors of
milkshakes and Clayton Christensen's
group went in and instead of just diving
into the question of how do they grow
this revenue source they asked the
question what job did you hire that
milkshake for and it turns out the
consumer who is buying the milk shake
for breakfast needed something that was
portable and easy to eat or drink and so
but
the form factor of a milkshake was
high-calorie it was easy to hold and it
was something they could drink in their
truck there was like a lot of people who
needed this sort of high-calorie they
were usually doing a lot of physical
labor that's what they needed this
milkshake for and and so he uses this
framework of what job are you hiring a
product to do in a lot of different
different areas to great effect and I
I even used that framework for a lot of
my portfolio companies but he applies
this actually in life especially as a
parent what job does my child need me to
do and I think that's a really
interesting question to ask what job
does my spouse need me to do or what job
does my parent need me to do and I try
to actually think about this every
morning and when I wake up in the
morning I it and I I think about the
most important people in my life and
this is exactly the question I try to
ask myself and it's been incredible how
I have figured out things that people
need me to do for them in those really
early hours is the morning because I've
really reflected on it and I'm not
reacting from a place of what I want to
do for them but rather what they need me
to do and then the third lesson that I
extracted from this was more recently in
Chapter eight clay Christensen talks
about the school of experience and I
really reflected on this chapter because
of my daughter who's now 12 years old
was going through something at school
that really made her have to advocate
for herself and in this chapter he talks
about how you have to help your children
learn how to do difficult things and
that's probably the most important role
that we play as a parent and we have to
equip them for the challenges of life
and one of the things that I've really
thought about is that advocating for
yourself and figuring out what's the
right solution
for you is an important skill set for
kids to have and I felt like at 12 my
daughter should have that by now
so recently she was in a class that she
was deeply unhappy with and she decided
she wanted to drop the class that she
felt she wasn't learning anyway and so
she wanted to find an opportunity to
drop the class and potentially do
something else with the time so I asked
her for a plan and I didn't help her
with it
but when she came back she had not only
figured out how to drop the class she
had gone all the signatures she needed
from the teachers she also had figured
out a new class that she could ta for so
she could have credits during that
period she figured out an online course
that she could sign up for
she found other students to take the
online course with her she found a
teacher who was willing to tutor her
because she wanted an in-person
experience as well and she had done all
of this on her own at the age of 12 and
it was amazing to me mostly because I
wouldn't have thought that she was
capable of that if I hadn't kind of
forced her into that role and I think
that it gave her self-confidence as well
and gave it gave me self-confidence as a
parent but this book how will you
measure your life I recommend it for
anyone who's there starting off in their
career in the middle of their career if
they have kids it's it's relevant for
almost everyone because it'll make you
stop and think about where you spend
your time how you spend your time and
why you do it just to change things up a
bit I'm going to talk about a second
book which is fiction and I read about
50% fiction and 50% nonfiction and my
favorite book that I keep recommending
to every single person I meet is this
book that I read probably six or seven
years ago it's called the dove keepers
and it's by one of my favorite authors
her name is Alice Hoffman and this book
is about a fictionalized account 2,000
years ago of 900 Jews held out against
Roman armies on in this area in Israel
called Masada
it's a mountain in the Judean Desert
it's a place that you can still actually
visit and it is long known that it was
the last stronghold of the Jews in this
period and according to sort of this
ancient rumor there were two women and
five children who ultimately survived
and so the Romans essentially attacked
this fortress that was at the top of
this mountain by building essentially a
ramp up to the top of the mountain over
two years and so the the nine hundred
Jews who were waiting it out on the top
of this mountain knew that this was
coming for some time and basically all
commit suicide at the end and the the
rumour was that two women and five
children survived and this story takes
the perspective of one of the survivors
and talks about how they escaped and the
story was so beautiful and so compelling
that for all this time I've wanted to go
to Masada and this next February we as a
family are going to Israel and of course
one of the stops is going to be Masada
because I absolutely have to see this
place and I also absolutely need to see
this incredible Roman ramp that was
built to the top of the mountain so I
think I'm gonna try to reread this book
actually before I end up in Masada in a
few months the third book that I really
loved is a book called the righteous
mind why good people are divided by
politics and religion and it's written
by Jonathan hate H AI D T and he is a
social
psychologist I love this book because it
clarified for me a lot of things that
I've been feeling for so long around I
actually have a lot of different types
of friends and and friends who I think
would violently disagree with one
another on a number of different topics
I love them all and I also know that if
I got on to the wrong topic of
conversation and confessed my beliefs to
them that we would end up in some
serious disagreements with one another
and as a high school debater I was
forced to actually take the opposite
side of what I believed multiple times
and I think it allowed me to explore
ideas more completely as a result and
and so I've I feel like on some level I
have sympathy for when someone believes
something fairly different from what I
believe I try to keep it a relatively
open mind but what I what I appreciate
about what Jonathan wrote was that he
said that one thing that that really
struck me morality binds and blinds and
what he meant with that statement was
that there is this deep-seated need for
people to actually belong and he
actually says it's one thing which I
thought was really interesting we do
moral reasoning not to reconstruct the
actual reasons why we ourselves came to
a judgement we reason to find the best
possible reason why somebody else ought
to join us in our judgments in other
words reasoning is used to back up not
question judgment these days and that's
sort of a natural inclination of humans
the other thing that he points out is
that there's a group of people we're all
kind of part of it if you're listening
to this podcast Western educated
industrialized rich
Democratic people he calls them weird
because it's Western educated
industrialized rich and democratic we
are actually outliers when it comes to
morality the vast majority of the world
actually believes in strong communities
sacred things family religion nation
states and people who live in weird
locations are much more into
individualistic rights and the way we
perceive the world is not necessarily
majority opinion he also talks about how
religion itself can create incredibly
cohesive altruistic moral communities
because they create a much bigger than
sense of self and it made me think of
this one time when I went to a volunteer
opportunity and it was at the County
Fairgrounds and we're trying to help
people get free dentist work done and
you might think you know how big of a
need is that well it turns out that in
California when this was done and in Bay
Area there were people lined up for
someone to look at their teeth or help
them starting at 2:30 in the morning
they were opening up the gates at 8:00
and there were literally hundreds of
volunteers who had lined up to help
these people and literally every
volunteer there came from some church
and it really made me think about how
how much that altruistic moral sense and
the sense that there is something bigger
than yourself creates incredible
community and an incredible sense of
giving the other thing that I learned
from this book was
that there are many ways to think about
morality and and many of us are really
limiting how we look at morality to a
few things that we think are super
important but that not everyone believes
that so he talks about how important
care and release from harm is he talks
about how another element of morality is
fairness he also talks about how loyalty
is important to some people
authority liberty and sanctity and so he
calls the sort of the six kind of taste
buds of morality and that there are many
places where the idea of what care and
fairness and liberty and loyalty and
authority that all these things can
actually seem very foreign or the
interpretation of these values can be
very different so as an example he talks
about how care for someone can be
reflected as freedom from oppression and
that same care can also be interpreted
as how do you make sure that you help
the people who have made sacrifices for
their group or fairness can be
interpreted as civil and human rights
and then on the other hand fairness can
be interpreted as rewarding in
proportion to your contribution or
fairness can be social justice and that
we recognize that the wealthy exploit
the middle class and the poor and then
at the same time that same idea of
fairness is again rewarding in
proportion to contribution so it's just
really interesting to see how these
different ideas can translate in such
different ways and how we might all say
that one thing is important
but we can actually interpret it in
completely different ways and when you
look at the language that's being stated
like many times you can actually agree
with both sides it's just that we might
be two ships passing in the night and so
the righteous mind was important to me
because it allowed me to open up my mind
to different perspectives and allowed me
to make sure that I know where my biases
stand and why I might have them and
allowed me to be more empathetic to
people with very different views so
those are the three books that I have
really found to be profoundly impactful
either in actual decisions or the way I
think or travel plans the righteous mind
the Dove keepers and how will I measure
my life or actually how will you measure
your life so the three books are the
righteous mind the Dove keepers and how
will you measure your life thank you so
much hey guys this is Tim again just a
few more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet Friday do
you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday event provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do it could include a
favorite articles that I have read and
that I've shared with my close friends
for instance and it's very short it's
just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek
come that's four hour workweek calm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy
[Applause]